Ideally parents let their children
learn how to help themselves.
Parents who neglect their children or those
who are overly involved, achieve the opposite.
Their children often learn helplessness
— and hence believe that they can neither
control their life, nor change their environment.
Learned helplessness was first discovered by
two researchers who conditioned
dogs to endure electric shocks.
Martin Seligman and Steven F. Maier conducted
their experiment with three groups of dogs.
Dogs from the first group were caged and
made to wait for a period of time before
being released. These dogs were
what's known as the control group.
The second group were also caged and got electric
shocks from below. When they pressed a button,
the shocks stopped. They learned
that they could stop the pain.
The third group of dogs were exposed to the
shocks, but had no way of stopping them.
After the conditioning, all three groups were
put into a box that gave shocks
on one side, but not the other.
The first and second group of
dogs quickly learned to avoid
being shocked by jumping over the wall
that separated the two sides of the box.
The third group of dogs made no attempt
to avoid the shocks -they had developed
a cognitive expectation that they
could not avoid the pain. Seligman
and Maier attributed this to learned helplessness.
Children can also be affected, as
this oversimplified story attests.
This is the story of Joe. While
other kids were allowed to run,
this cute little boy was put in a
walker so he couldn't hurt himself.
And so, from early on, Joe learned
that the world is a dangerous place.
On the rare occasions that his father was home, he
told Joe to toughen up, and become a strong boy.
But without a role model, Joe
lacked the motivation to live
up to his dad’s expectations.
He began to feel inferior.
Over time this feeling got stronger.
Whenever there was a problem his
mother would jump in to help.
Joe began to internalize the belief that he
couldn’t help himself when
confronted with challenges.
Whenever he had to make a major
decision, he’d ask his mom for advice.
Deep inside he resented her for not
allowing him to become more independent.
What are your thoughts? How can we help
those that fail to see the path out of
their toxic life? How can we help them
to help themselves? Share your thoughts
and your own experience with learned
helplessness in the comments below!
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com